I'm excited to talk about making
PowerPoint presentations with R
Markdown today.
This is a project
that has been--
we've been working
on for a while now.
And it's nice to finally
present some of the material.
So you're probably
wondering why would you
want to create a PowerPoint
presentation from R Markdown.
Well, there's a
number of reasons,
but I'm going to
point out a few.
So one reason is that
everyone knows PowerPoint.
It's a standard communication
tool, especially used
in business.
People learn to speak the
language of PowerPoint.
And the fact of
the matter is it's
very useful because it works.
It's very flexible, you
can make slides fast,
and everyone has personal
experience with it.
Some people love it.
Some people not so much but
everyone has an opinion on it
because we've all
touched this tool.
But your work, of
course, is coded in R.
And that's because your
code is your product.
So your output is
a manifestation
of your codes of plots,
tables, model output, that's
all coming from your code.
Well that's where R Markdown
becomes very useful.
R Markdown makes your
work reproducible.
You can weave text and
code to produce elegantly
formatted output.
You can use things
like R Notebooks
for doing interactive analysis.
R Markdown, if you
haven't used it, is--
will allow you to create a
number of different output
types--
reports, apps, dashboards, HTML
docs, PDFs, Word documents,
but not PowerPoint,
not until now.
So now you can make PowerPoint
presentations with R Markdown.
As of RStudio version 1.2,
you can render PowerPoint
presentations from the IDE.
This combines two great things,
PowerPoint and R Markdown.
You can think of it as
the Reese's peanut butter
cup of presentation software.
I'm not sure which
one's the chocolate
and which one's
the peanut butter,
but you can tell I put this
together during the Halloween
time period.
So let me show you a quick
demo of doing PowerPoint
presentations with RStudio.
So this is RStudio
preview version 1.2.
If I go up to file,
new file R Markdown
and then I choose presentation
down at the bottom,
I have an option
the new PowerPoint.
I click OK, and this is
an R Markdown document.
Again, if you've never seen
R Markdown, it's going to--
it will contain the
pros, some narrative,
plus some R code
chunks, some things
about R that you might want
to include in your document.
And then the output type here
is PowerPoint presentation.
And the way you create the
PowerPoint presentations is you
hit this knit button.
I want to hit this.
I'll give it a name.
And it generates
a PowerPoint deck
with the content, some
bullets, some R code output,
and a nice little plot.
Now if you don't want to use
the RStudio ID, that's fine.
You don't have to
use the RStudio ID.
You can always render
this programmatically.
This all works with
open source software.
You can do this inside
of an R console.
Type in render, give it the
name and the output format,
and that will also generate
the PowerPoint output.
So some of the benefits
of using R Markdown here.
Well, in this book,
R for Data Science,
there's this lovely chapter
at the end of this book.
If you haven't seen it, I
recommend that you read it.
It's about R Markdown about
communicating insights
to decision makers,
and it makes the point
that R Markdown is a great
way to influence other people
in your organization
and other people that
will be making decisions
based on the work
that you do in
your data science.
It will allow you to do better
data science because you'll
be collaborating with
other data scientists who
are able to read your
code, understand your code,
and reproduce your code.
And it gives you this
nice environment in which
you can do data science.
When you put your
narrative together
with the code and the output
into a single document,
I would argue through
personal experience
that you do better data science.
It allows you to think more
clearly and understand why
you're doing what you're doing.
From a presentation
standpoint of PowerPoint,
I think one of the
big takeaways here
is that you're
just going to spend
a lot less time iterating
on presentation slides
and a lot more
time doing what you
do best, which is data science.
So how does it work?
Well, you write your code
in R Markdown format.
And then you knit the code
with the knitter package.
And what knitter does is it
takes your R Markdown code,
and it converts it
into Markdown format.
And Markdown format
is a universal format
that can be put into this
other system called Pandoc.
And Pandoc is what actually
converts the Markdown document
into PowerPoint.
Now all of this is already
bundled into the IDE,
so it's seamless,
but this is what's
happening under the covers.
So I want to focus on this
Pandoc piece for a second.
What is Pandoc?
Well, Pandoc is the open source
software that converts files
from one format to another.
You can think of as
a Swiss army knife.
And PowerPoint output was added
to Pandoc and Pandoc version 2.
The initial release
was in December 2017,
and then there was a number
of progressive updates
that happened at the
beginning of this year
to allow you to create these--
this PowerPoint output.
And Pandoc is bundled
into the RStudio IDE.
And the RStudio IDE
version 1.2 has the ability
to create PowerPoint documents
in RStudio Connect as
of version 1.6.4, which came
out a few months ago that also
has the ability to support
PowerPoint documents.
Now a lot of this work
here with Pandoc was done
by a developer-- a
Haskell developer--
Pandoc's written Haskell--
and he works out of--
he's a professor at
Johns Hopkins University,
and his name's Jesse Rosenthal.
And Jesse's actually
on the call today,
so it's great to have him
here and join in the webinar.
But most of this
development work was--
that allows us to convert
documents into PowerPoint
was done by Jesse.
R Markdown's not the only
way to do document conversion
into PowerPoint.
You have these other R packages
that you might have used,
and these are great R packages.
I've use some of them.
They allow you to have fine
grain control over what
happens on those slides.
And some of these
will have features
that aren't available
in the Markdown format--
conversion format.
So these packages
are still relevant.
You might still find
these very useful.
Let's talk about use cases
for creating PowerPoint
presentations from R Markdown.
The first one is to
render the presentation
and then customize
the presentation.
And that's probably going
to be a very common use case
for your PowerPoint slides.
You're going to output the
text, the tables, and the plots
to PowerPoint, and then you're
in and modify these or copies
into your final presentation.
I'll give you an example.
This is a notebook that
analyzes bank data,
and in the course
of this analysis,
I create a whole bunch
of visualizations
that are interesting.
And normally what I would
do with these visualizations
is I would take these and
I'd copy these one at a time
into my PowerPoint presentation.
My PowerPoint presentation
would become a mess,
and then I'd lose track
of which ones are which.
And I'd have to go back and up--
when I go back to
update my analysis,
then things become out of sync.
Be much better just
to build a render
all the slides in one
shot from this notebook,
and that's what you can do
with the PowerPoint output.
So I come up here and say
knit this presentation.
This will go through and
spin up a new R session,
run all of the R code
through that session,
and then generate a
PowerPoint presentation.
So here's the slides.
You can see that I've
got my narrative again.
And then I've got
some graphs here.
And I can take these
graphs, and I can copy these
into my final presentation.
I've got a table, and
that's really great, too.
And I can-- if I don't
like the order here,
I can just movies
around if I need to.
But I don't like-- if I want
to change the background,
change my template, I
can do that as well.
Choose a different template.
If I'm not happy with
the table, the table
renders as a PowerPoint
table, so I can go ahead
and change that table design.
And I can-- and at this--
and I can come in here
and say I've got more
than one data source.
I've got data sources.
I'm going to change that.
And now I've really broken
the reproducibility paradigm.
I've actually gone through
and made some changes.
And now if I go back
and re-do the slides,
I'm going to have
to do those again.
But I'd argue that you're
much better off because you
can produce a lot of
these at the same time,
and you can keep them
anchored to that R Markdown
document that explains
what you're doing.
So we think this will
be a pretty common use
case for taking slides and
then manipulating them.
People like to customize their
PowerPoint presentations.
And chances are your
slides are going
to be one part of a larger
presentation that ends up
getting delivered to the
executive or the client
or whoever you're trying
to communicate with.
And that will work
great in this work flow.
The other use case is to
publish to RStudio Connect.
What is RStudio Connect?
It's a publishing platform
for R. It runs your R code,
and it allows you to share your
shiny apps, R Markdown reports,
and much, much more.
So in this use case,
what you're going to do
is you're going to output the
entire presentation with R
Markdown, and then you're
going to render updates
programmatically on a schedule.
And then you'll distribute
those PowerPoint presentations
by email, and you
can even design
them to accept user inputs.
So this is a little bit easier
to show than to explain.
Here's another presentation
that I'm using.
It's the stock data.
And this is a parameters
R Markdown document.
And if you haven't seen
parameters R Markdown before,
they're extremely powerful.
You set up parameters
here and then inputs here.
This is going to be the
Tesla stock ticker symbol.
And if I want to call that
in my R markdown document,
I just use param string symbol.
So these become very
useful in their own right
even regardless of how
your accepting user
inputs or what
output formats you're
using parameters R Markdown.
Parameterization is extremely
powerful in R Markdown
documents.
But here what I
can do is I can say
I'm going to knit this thing.
I'll go ahead and knit
it with parameters.
And I'll choose the
IBM report I guess.
I'll knit this document.
Great.
Now I have a document for
the IBM candlestick chart.
And this is what I want,
but I can't anticipate
everybody's needs here with all
of the different stock tickers
that they might need.
Nor am I able to
automate this every day.
I don't have the ability
to update this every day.
I have to be able to
automate it with the system.
So I want to make sure
that this report gets
generated daily and sent
out to the people that
are interested in it.
So what I do is I publish
this to RStudio Connect.
And I can do that with
this Publish button.
I choose RStudio
Connect, and this is what
RStudio Connect books like.
Here's the default report.
That's going to be
the Tesla report.
If I want to change the report
ticker, I can go in here
and I can say I
want to change IBM.
And you could run that report.
I'm not going to run the
report because I've already
done it for you.
It's right here.
And then if I want to, I can
go ahead and email this report
to myself, or I come in here
and I can schedule this report
to run every day and then send
me an email when it's complete.
And I can add more
people to this report.
And that-- what
that report looks
like is if I go to my inbox, can
see that I just got the report.
It's got this nice
graphic here that tells me
that IBM closed at 120.03.
Then I come down
here to the end,
and I can see that I've
attached the PowerPoint
presentation to the email.
And again this is going to be
the updated report that I just
ran.
So you can see that this
would be a very useful way
to communicate your insights
with a lot of people
who prefer to get their
information by email
and PowerPoint.
I personally know
a lot of people
in that boat that
would like to get
their information
communicated to them in email
and PowerPoint.
Perhaps you do as well.
The nice thing here
is that you only
have to write the code once,
and then RStudio Connect
can handle the scheduling
and the distribution
and accept the user
inputs systematically.
So those are some use cases.
Let's talk about features.
So the PowerPoint output accepts
most of the Markdown features
that are supported in
other document formats.
For example, inline
formatting is supported.
So this is what the 9 formatting
looks like in your code,
and this is how it gets
rendered into PowerPoint.
Supports lists.
LaTex.
So if you're putting in
math equations, hyperlinks,
of course, block quotes,
images from the web--
this went out and snagged
an image from the web
and then put it into my slide--
images from file.
This actually took
an image from a file
and put it into my slide.
You can add captions to images.
You can add a link to
caption to the image.
Or you can link the image.
In this case, what happens
is if I click this image,
this will take me to the
R for Data Science page.
Sports tables.
So you write your
tables and Markdown code
that looks like this, and
they get rendered like this.
Notice there is a
caption down here.
It also supports these really
nifty features like columns.
So columns are great.
What you do here is
you create these--
this fence-- this
called a fence div--
and you put all the contents
for the first column here.
And you put all the contents
for the second column here.
And then it will show up
in your two-column layout.
It's called the
two-content layout.
It's two columns and-- two
contents of two columns.
It supports speaker notes.
Speaker notes are very useful.
Again, you put a
sensitive here, and you
can put the speaker
notes that'll
render in the presentation.
And templates.
The templates become
very useful also,
and I will be talking about
that a little bit later.
And, of course, this
translation supports R Code.
That's the whole point of this.
You want to be able to put
R Code into your R Markdown
documents.
What kind of R Code
does it support?
Well, any of the R Code
that's in your R Code chunks
and that typically is
going to look like code.
And your code is--
gets highlighted.
The syntax of your code gets
highlighted in the output
but automatically.
Tables.
So if you call the cable
function, which is in knitter,
it will create a
table in PowerPoint.
GG plot or any
other visualization,
it will render that
image on a content slide.
And if you do something
interactive like an HTML
widgets-- here I'm
using diagraphs--
the rendering process will go--
if you have installed
the web shot package,
the rendering process
will go and grab
a web screenshot of your
interactive visualization
and include it in your
PowerPoint presentation.
And finally Shiny.
How do you include Shiny in
your PowerPoint presentations?
Shiny's interactive.
PowerPoint presentations
are static.
So obviously you can't put
Shiny inside of higher point.
That would be ridiculous.
What you're going
to do instead is
you're going to put a static
image of your Shiny application
on your slide and then
link that to your Shiny
application, which
will be hosted
in Shiny app's I/O, RStudio
Connect, or Shiny server.
So I will show you an example.
In the course of my analysis, I
created this Shiny application,
set customer tracker app.
The nice thing about
this is it allows
me to drill down into
subgroups and other segments.
But obviously I can't put all
of those segments or groups
into a PowerPoint presentation.
So what do I do?
I go back to the code, and I
include this line include app.
And I put the URL
for that application
into my presentation.
Then when I knit
this process, it's
going to go and take a
screenshot of that Shiny
application and put it
back into my presentation.
For example, this deck
shows the total segment.
And the total group gives
me some high-level results
and some details.
And then it says use the Shiny
app to explore other segments
and groups.
And this image here
is a linked image.
And I can click on
this image and it--
I seem to have lost my
PowerPoint presentation.
Let's try that again.
So when I click on
this image, this
will take me back to
my Shiny application.
And this Shiny-- this
will allow your views--
your viewers to interact
with your application.
Choose a subgroup.
And I've even put
a download link
here to take a snapshot
of this report that
is formatted in
Excel and allows you
to see the report
that you've dug into.
Gives you all the
data to do, cross tabs
if you want to do that.
But what I've done here is I've
tied PowerPoint presentation
and Excel output and
a Shiny application
and put them all on top
of the same code base.
So let's talk about resources.
What resources are available?
The first place
to go to get help
would probably R
Markdown to RStudio.com.
That's our website
about R Markdown.
There's also a new book
that's out called R Markdown--
The Definitive Guide.
It gives you information
about all of the output types
and everything that you'd
want to know that R Markdown.
I've created a Getting Started
page and a troubleshooting page
for PowerPoint
output specifically,
so I recommend taking
a look at those.
If you have specific
questions about your work,
then community.RStudio.com
is a great place
to connect with other people.
And then if you do find
any issues, please let us
know by submitting issues to
the R Markdown GitHub repo.
I want to address some
frequently asked questions.
There is a question
about getting started
about using templates
and presentations that we
get frequently.
So this is the
Getting Started page.
If I come down
here to templates,
you can see that the way
you set up a template
is with this reference doc.
And the template supports
four of the many layouts
that are in an RStudio--
or in a PowerPoint template.
These are the
layouts that you want
to include in your template
for R Markdown documents.
The first one is
the title layout.
So this will give you the title
and the subtitle on this slide.
The next one is
the section header.
And the section header will
only render the content.
It won't render--
I'm sorry-- will only render
the header and not the content.
The title and content
slide, which you typically
think of as the main slide, and
then the two-content layout,
which allows you to do columns.
Now layouts are important
because Markdown doesn't allow
you to programmatically
change the design
or size of your presentation.
So what it does is it actually--
Pandoc actually ships with a
4 by 3 vanilla template that
is used to render
presentations by default.
So if you want to use
a widescreen format,
you're going to have to
create a widescreen template
and include that as a custom
template here in your reference
doc.
If you want to
change the background
or if you want to
change the layout--
the place holders
in any way, that's
all going to happen
with the template.
The next thing I
want to talk about
is structuring the presentation.
So a PowerPoint present--
this gets little detailed,
but I think it's
important to go through.
PowerPoint presentations
have a hierarchy
of title, section, and content
whereas markdown documents have
a hierarchy of
headers and contents.
So in order for the PowerPoint
presentation to get structured,
Pandoc has to determine which
markdown header level should
be used for the
PowerPoint slide level.
So, for example, in
this Markdown document,
you have a hierarchy of
headers that go from 1 to 5.
And this header is
the one that Pandoc
is going to use as the
slide level by default.
And it's going to use
it as a slide level
because it's the
first slide that
has content associated with it.
So everything that gets
rendered above this
is going to be turn
into sections--
section slides, and
everything below this
is going to be turned into sub
headers on the content slide.
Now if you didn't want this
to be the content slide
and you wanted this
to be the slide level,
you would change slide level
to 2 because 2 would mesh--
would match up to the two
hashtags on this R Markdown
section header.
So you probably don't have
to worry too much about this
because the defaults should
work well for you in most cases.
If you want to avoid
this issue altogether,
you can just use the same
level header for everything,
and then everything will be
rendered as content slides.
The way that the
slides get broken up,
follows these five rules.
I'm not going to go through
all these right now.
But just know that
there is a way to--
that they get
rendered and there's
an easy way to find out
what those rules are.
Just go to the Getting Started
page and it will explain it.
So troubleshooting.
What types of issues might
you expect to run into?
Well, some of the common
things that we see
is that the PowerPoint
presentation gets broken
and you get a message
that says that it needs
to be repaired or removed.
Or you get this weird
one, which doesn't even
give you anything at all.
And typically the
reason for these errors
is that the Markdown
code that you wrote
looks something like
this where everything
is condensed together.
And when you write R--
when you write
Markdown code, you
need to put spaces in between
the content, the title,
and the speaker notes.
And if you go and put those
spaces back in and then
restart PowerPoint--
PowerPoint's an
old program, needs
to be restarted every time you
get into this weird state--
if you go back, put the
spaces, and restart PowerPoint,
this should read render
more successfully.
So that would be the
first thing to try.
How do I put an image in
a text on the same slide?
There's two ways to put images
and text on the same slide.
One is to use captions.
And if you use a
caption in Markdown,
it's going to look
something like this.
And if you use caption
in a code junk,
it's going to look
something like this.
And you can write very
long captions here.
So this is actually a very
workable solution, probably
the easiest solution
to your code.
If you-- and table
support captions as well,
you have to use table
caption on those.
So the other way to do
it is to use columns.
And this uses the
two-content layout
that you could put your text
on one side and your image
on the other side.
You could actually add a
caption to this image as well.
So this is a great way to
separate text and columns.
You could put images on
both columns or an image
on the side and text
on the other side.
But then the next
question, of course,
is, well, how do I
control the placement
of the images and text?
And there is no way to
do that programmatically.
You have to do that
with the templates
as I mentioned earlier.
So here what I've done is I've
taken the two-content layout
in my template, and I've stacked
one of the content placeholders
on top of the other one.
And it renders
quite nicely, allows
me to put an image on the
bottom and text on the top.
The only issue here is that
you only get one of these,
so you have to stick
with this layout
throughout your presentation.
But this will work really
nicely for this layout.
If you need more
programmatic control,
then you're probably going
to be in the situation
where you need one
of those R packages
we talked about earlier.
How do I control the
size of an image?
Well, you can't.
Pandoc automatically resizes
images to fit a placeholder.
Currently it's not possible
programmatically change image
size.
How do I create a build slide?
Build slides are very useful.
Currently that's not supported.
So you can't do a
build slide today.
That's where you click the
button and bullet point 1, 2,
3 show up in order.
How do I render a
presentation programmatically?
We talked about that already
through the render command.
And how do I check
my Markdown code.
So sometimes it's useful
to check your Markdown
code if you're trying to
debug your rendering process.
And the way you
do that is you use
the clean equals
false option, and that
will output the
Markdown file that gets
generated in the
rendering process.
You can open that up and see
if it's creating the Markdown
that you intended to create.
So all of the things
that you saw today
were generated in R Markdown
with the PowerPoint output
including this presentation
that you're looking at today.
This was also generated
from an R Markdown document.
And all of that is
stored in a GitHub repo
under the Soledge category as--
with-- and it's
called PowerPoint.
I've included a number
of vignettes in here
as well that I didn't
show today but are
very useful in understanding
how these features work.
If you're interested
in looking at that,
you can download the GitHub
repo today and try it out.
But make sure that you install
R Studio version 1.2 preview.
And you can get there by
googling RStudio Preview,
downloading the latest copy,
and trying this out today.
So I hope you have a lot of fun
making PowerPoint presentations
with R Markdown.
And thank you very
much for the time.
I'll-- let me toggle over
and take some questions now.
What customizations of
PowerPoint can you do within R?
I think the best--
can you do any
customizations on tables?
Yeah, so that's all
going to be dictated--
I think the question is can
I programmatically change
the table color
or shape or size.
All of that is going to be
dictated by the templates.
So you're going
to want to define
all of that in the template.
So if you want to
change the link color,
for example, you'll
change the color
of the link in the
template and then
Pandoc will automatically render
those links in that color.
Are those RMD codes embedded
in the PowerPoint file?
The RMD codes embedded
in the PowerPoint file.
If I understand
correctly, you're
talking about the
syntax highlighting
and how the code is being
outputted to the PowerPoint
file.
That's in the echo.
But I'm a little confused
about this question
because you won't actually
have code in the PowerPoint.
There's no code that's going
to run in the PowerPoint file.
You're just going to echo
the code into the PowerPoint
slides, and Pandoc is going
to do the syntax highlighting
for you.
I hope that answers
the question.
If not, let me know.
Can you trigger an email
based on output in R Connect?
So the emails are--
you can manually email yourself.
Let me just showed this again.
So the way you
email in PowerPoint
is you can email yourself here.
That's one way to email.
The other way to email
is to send an email
after it has been rendered--
after it's been completed--
after it's completed
the schedule.
So that's the way--
so you can-- basically
you can send emails either
on demand or programmatically.
Good question.
Does it support
biv tech citations
as a footnote of the slide.
So the-- I don't
think I've tried that.
That's a good question.
I haven't tried that.
There are some footnotes
that belong to the layouts,
and you might have seen
that in the presentation.
So I would have to see
if the layouts actually
supported that footnote.
Regarding my Shiny question,
what I'm envisioning
is a button in my Shiny app that
an end user can press that will
output a PowerPoint, which will
contain an image of the graph
that the end user
has customized.
So here's the rule
of thumb with Shiny.
You can do anything with Shiny.
It's basically unbounded.
So if you want to have
a Shiny application that
renders a PowerPoint
presentation from a button
press and then allows you to
download that or even pipe that
to some other system,
you can do all of that.
And you might use an R package
to render that PowerPoint
presentation, or you
might use R Markdown file
to render that presentation.
It's really up to you to
determine how to do that.
But if you use the
R Markdown format,
you'll want to use
that render command
that we showed you to generate
the PowerPoint output.
Do custom templates need to
be stored someplace specific?
No, you can reference
them from any location
in the yaml header.
Does it matter if you
create the PowerPoint
on a Windows laptop or a Mac?
Will the images work if you open
the PowerPoint in the other OS
later on?
Yeah, the cross platform
will work just fine.
Do these templates allow
for background images?
Yes, you can put images
on the template there.
That will work.
Can you custom-- can use a
custom layout that is not one
of the four mentioned above?
No, you have to use those
four layouts that are
mentioned in the documentation.
Any idea when this will be
released for real and not
in the preview?
We don't have--
I don't have a release date
for RStudio 1.2 for you today.
But please keep
check of our blog.
You'll see that there's lots
of updates that are coming out.
We're very excited
about the next release.
Can you create a PowerPoint
graph with the data behind it.
So someone else can modify the
graph and PowerPoint directly?
No, that is not a feature
that is supported today.
What about font size
or type of font?
Again, all controlled
from the template.
I'm just going to pause here
on some of these questions
because there are a lot of
questions that are stating
I like to have fine grained
control over my PowerPoint
presentations.
And if you really want
fine grained control,
you should either use
one of those R packages
and code those up explicitly, or
you should do the custom work.
That would be my recommendation.
How can I choose
different slide packages
in R such as I/O slides?
So if you want to do
different slides--
I want to--
I think this is the question.
If you come up here
and do new file,
R markdown, presentation,
you can see here's
I/O slides and
sliding in beamer.
And this-- and we actually
support more than just this.
So there are other ways
to create presentations.
Hope that's-- hope that
answers your question.
Does it support
biv text citation?
I already answered that.
Is there a reason--
a release date for R Studio 1.2?
I answered that.
Usually I have to create slides
with the company standard
design.
Is there a way for R
Markdown to accommodate
PowerPoint templates?
Yes, there are-- templates
are a big feature in R--
in PowerPoint-- rendering
PowerPoint presentations,
and you can do that from
the reference doc that
is here in the reference doc.
And I would point you to the
help documentation online.
Can you customize different
slides differently
like a two-content
layout for one slide
and another layout
for another side?
So you have-- these
are the four layouts.
I think this is a good
question actually.
These are the two layouts
for content slides,
and these are the only
two layouts that you have.
Now you can modify these to be
top and bottom, side by side,
big and small, but these are
the only two that you have.
And the way you use this one
is you specify column names
or columns, and columns
look something like this.
And the way you
specify the other one
is not to use columns.
So those are the
two options today.
Maybe we'll have more
options in the future.
Please submit your feedback.
We always love to
hear from our people--
from our customers like
what they think is useful.
Can you embed VBA code?
That is a dark, dark question,
and I'm just going to move on.
How to break flex table data
frames into different slides?
Not sure what a flex table
is, so if you're there,
Ashish, follow up with me
or add another question--
add another follow up so I
know what a flex table is.
Is it possible to have
more than 4 templates?
No, just the four layouts today.
But we appreciate the
feedback, and maybe we
can add some more in the future.
Can I email you for other
specific questions I have.
Yes, I would go on to--
for other follow up,
I'll go on to
community.RStudio.com,
and I would--
I'm on there, and other--
and [INAUDIBLE] on there,
and multiple people
are on there that could address
these types of questions.
So please look for us on
community.RStudio.com.
Will you create a repository
for sharing PowerPoint templates
that can be used with R Markdown
for making these presentations?
Yeah, that's not
a bad suggestion.
I thought about that.
There's a number of
other issues at RStudio
that are kind of like
that where maybe you
need a collection
of CSS templates,
or you need a collection of
add ins that are really useful.
Some PowerPoint templates.
I think it's a pretty
reasonable question.
My best suggestion right now
is check out the GitHub repo
that I pointed to earlier--
this PowerPoint.
And this has a
number of templates
already inside of it
that you could use
So we don't have a 1.2
release date for you today.
For the finer grain control, I
recommend the officer package.
Yes, so that's exactly right.
If you want fine grain
control where everything is--
the images are
place exactly where
you want it to be in size
and layouts are complex
and you've got other things
going on in that slide,
by all means, use an R
package or do it by hand.
The R Markdown-- keep in mind
the R Markdown format is really
used for creating reproducible
documents that you
can collaborate on and
do data science with.
And they're used to output into
multiple output formats, not
just PowerPoint but to Word,
HTML, PDF, and many more.
I think that's a
good place to pause.
I really appreciate
the questions
and really appreciate
the attendance.
Thanks everyone.